hallöchen meine lieben Freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer Runde goat
Simulator dieses Video
habe ich vor acht einhalb Jahren
hochgeladen einen neuen besten Freund
guckt ihr edel das mein neuer bester
Freund erst Steve
einfach nicht ich habe lieber Geflecht
ich weiß es doch auch nicht
weiß meine lieben Freunde ist warum die
Entwickler vom neuen goat Simulator 3
sich gedacht haben Mensch das Spiel
kommen zwei erste drei Tage offiziell
raus aber einer Person einer einzigen
Person in Deutschland geben wir das
Spiel schon drei Tage vorher und diese
Person bin ich
ich weiß nicht warum man sowas macht
weil diese Ziege wird gleich komplett in
den
[Musik]
es geht los
ich versuche aufgeregt weil du nicht
Freunde ich bin der allererste
Deutschland der Gott Simulator 3 spielen
darf was ist das denn für ein oh ich
habe mich schon bewegen hi wie bin ich
hier noch
guck mal das Ding kennen wir doch auf
goat Simulator 1 das war unser äh Dings
Turm glaube ich der ziegenturm wo wir da
noch reingehen konnten und er hat
endlich mal aufgehört zu reden ich will
einfach nur raus ich will das Spiel
entdecken Mann ich habe so lange auf
dieses Spiel gewartet hey hey
ich schau zu dir
eine Stunde später
wir sind der allererste deutsche
YouTube-Kanal der goat Simulator 3
spielen darf und ich weiß ihr werdet
euch jetzt wahrscheinlich denken
Manchester soll das kack-spiel vor acht
Jahren waren vielleicht einige Freunde
geboren aber das ist so richtig witzige
Spiel und ich freue mich übertrieben du
auch ja ich werde dir auf jeden Fall
alles erstmal ein bisschen entdecken wir
haben in der Rampe
guck mal bin ich hier nicht meine Minute
drin und habe schon in den Sound
zerstört vorne sehe ich noch
sag mal geht alles kaputt wo ich
irgendwie gegen
das Spiel hat sich auf jeden Fall krank
verändert nicht nur die ganzen Physik
sondern auch die Grafik es sieht
wunderschön aus wir haben hier vorne
Schweine ihr seid auch mal ganz kurz
Hallo hi
da bin ich gerade hier in die Scheiße
reingesprungen
[Musik]
der Bürgermeister angefurzt hier vorne
haben wir noch einen anderen
[Musik]
was Bruder ich bin allerdings sagen dass
wir jetzt tatsächlich uns mal kurz zu
dem ziegenturm hier bewegen denn wir
sollen ja irgendwas machen glaube ich ja
okay er gedrückt halten dann
synchronisieren wir uns mit dem
ziegenturm und irgendwas passiert das
ist glaube ich jetzt der offizielle
Start von goat Simulator 3 das meinte ja
der Bauer gerade schon auf der Kutsche
dass wir das als allererstes machen
sollen dass das so eine Art Portal
darstellt in diesem Tower ey schaut euch
mal diese Map an und ich glaube es gibt
noch viel mehr zu entdecken denn es gibt
auch noch einen Strand es gibt
Hochhäuser es gibt so unfassbar viele
Sachen zu entdecken no joke es gab in
den letzten 8 Jahren kein Spiel was neu
rausgekommen ist wo ich mich so sehr
darauf gefreut habe die goat Simulator 3
es steht einiges an unsere Challenge ist
dass wir drei Dingen Kopfstütze versetzt
Sprachen lernen Babbel da würde ich
sagen nehmen wir auf jeden Fall hier die
Menschen zack haben wir schon zwei von
drei und dann können wir noch hier
dieses Ding hier nehmen drei von drei
haben wir das auf jeden Fall schon mal
abgeschlossen aktualisierte Karte drücke
Tab um neue Events und andere Dinge auf
der Karte zu sehen
[Musik]
no way no way
wir haben so eine riesige Karte also
wenn ihr denkt dass dieser Bauernhof
hier das einzige ist was goat Simulator
3 zu bieten hat dann seid ihr wirklich
am Arsch denn es gibt viel viel mehr in
diesem Spiel wir verschaffen uns erstmal
ein bisschen Ausblick hier erstmal hier
hoch die Krone holen die gab es auch im
ersten Teil immer die ist nur im
Mehrspieler
[Musik]
es gibt Mehrspielermodus
schreibt mal vielleicht unten in die
Kommentare mit wem ich das überzeugen
soll ich freue mich so unfassbar krank
auf diese Spiel und ich freue mich erst
recht so unfassbar krank darauf die
ganze Map hier zu entdecken hier vorne
haben wir ein Taxi ich kann ich kann
ich kann Autos fahren
das ist nicht wahr
man kann in goat Simulator jetzt Autos
fahren
[Musik]
ein paar Sekunden später
müssen wir tatsächlich erstmal mitnehmen
wir können ja eh drücken dann können wir
lecken und dann können wir Gegenstände
mitnehmen ich kann natürlich noch die
komplette Steuerung aus dem ersten Teil
goat Simulator ich habe ja alle Teile
gespielt ich habe mir alle DLCs gekauft
das ist no joke meiner Ansicht nach das
witzigste Spiel der Welt ist es quasi
GTA für idiotische Kleinkinder wie mich
das ist eigentlich ganz schön also ich
nehme diesen jetzt einfach mal mit hier
rüber zu meinem ziegenturm den wir ja
hier links haben da können wir einmal
kurz hier hoch springen Zack und dann
haben wir hier vorne noch eine kleine
Toilette denn äh wir sehen tatsächlich
schon bzw mittlerweile sind jetzt nicht
mehr aber wir sollen tatsächlich hier
den ziegenturm Mal betreten Standort
vorhin eingeblendet oh Gott
[Musik]
wenn ich im Kölner Dom oder was
oh
das ist ein bisschen kaputt gegangen
glaube ich ja und jetzt öffnet sich eine
Tür
ja
[Musik]
ist das hier vorne ein Portal ich glaube
ja daher sind wir auch gekommen also
hüpfen wir mal ganz kurz über dieses
komische Dinge drüber und laufen wieder
zurück in unsere Welt denn da fühle ich
mich auch ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen
wohler guck mal unser Dixi Kloster ich
glaube ich würde das eher nach da vorne
stellen
[Musik]
oh mein Gott
ich habe gerade 3 Minuten lang probiert
dieses Dixi Klo hier richtig
hinzustellen okay nice wir haben jetzt
auf jeden Fall ein Dixi Klo wir haben
hier vorne eine Rampe wir haben hier
vorne unser Ziegen
[Musik]
also Freude wir haben eine ganze Menge
an Aufgaben die wir erledigen müssen und
ich freue mich extrem darauf diese Welt
hier zu entdecken ich bin so ein
bisschen baff gerade ich wusste nicht
dass es so viel gibt ich meine schaut
Euch das hier mal an das hier ist die
Karte wir sind hier wir sind bisher nur
in diesem Bereich hier rumgelaufen das
hier ist der komplette Bereich den es
gerade für uns gibt und das hier kommt
noch alles es gibt noch so viel zu
entdecken ich sehe da vorne noch
irgendwas grünes Leuchten das will ich
auf jeden Fall in diesem Video auch noch
mal eben kurz machen der sprinten wir
noch mal eben schnell hin ich weiß nicht
was das hier ist das sieht auf jeden
Fall aus wie so ein pferdeding
ich habe einen Sattel
verwende ist in der Nähe etwas zu
ermöglichen
[Musik]
dieses Spiel
ist das mit Abstand
dümmste aber auch geilste Spiel der Welt
übermorgen geht es weiter mit Teil 2 von
goat Simulator 3 mit Luca Lasten Daumen
hoch unter dem Video hier da abonniert
meinen Kanal und klickt auf die Glocke
um weitere Videos hier nicht zu
verpassen
was fällt ihm eine über mich drüber zu
laufen
wir baden
[Applaus]